foreign
welcome back now to the eight news now
covering to the Vegas strong 5K and mate
we're watching people already cross the
finish line we just saw the first
finisher of the 5K JC was talking to
folks who I think had done the one mile
aha still running fast but yeah he was
flying talk about smoke yeah so uh we
had over 2 000 entrance and I think she
said 2100 plus yes yes and uh they're
from all over the country and other
parts of the world as well as we
remember the this fifth um year since
the tragedy of one October Lots going on
uh there's dancers there's uh vendors
there's all kinds of stuff it really is
a fun day and it's family friendly and
the one thing I do want to point out
though of course because as much fun as
we're having we are marking a very
somber occasion and what you'll notice
is the runners do have in memory of yes
every single one yeah so you see those
names and you remember those stories
that have really just kind of burned
into our Consciousness here five years
later as as we honor their families yeah
and uh we're coming after we had a one
hour special last night with Brian in
Denise town at the healing Garden but we
want to talk more about what's happening
right here right now is the fifth annual
Vega strong 5K Sherry's been talking to
some folks what's going on Sherry
well we're at the finish line now uh
Heather and Nate and you can see the
first Runners are coming in this is what
the great buy they get bananas they get
fruit they get water but wow I mean some
of these Runners are so fast uh some of
them are First Responders others are
members of our community they've been
here living here and they know exactly
what this was like for them five years
ago so it means a lot to them they've
got family members and friends that
they're running for but mainly they're
just here to support each other and be
here for each other so JC is up he's
been talking to a couple of folks who
just finished but here's all the support
of the folks and check this out I mean
they're even running in wheelchairs and
such so it's a very wonderful morning JC
who are you talking to over there hey
Sherry I have the gentleman who just he
finished first the first one to finish
the 5K and congratulations you did it in
16 minutes and 45 seconds how do you
feel feel great it's very honored to
represent the city of Las Vegas
um I'm happy to be here and win the race
and you did it too because you work at
the Four Seasons so that you're
obviously right across from the tragedy
that night what was that night like for
you it was a heartbreaking moment I
heard that news when I wake up in the
morning uh ready to go to work uh
I cannot believe that happening right in
front of my working place so
[Music]
be out here today and do what you did
congratulations my friend you finished
go get some water I think you're
supposed to eat carbs or something like
that carb load I have one more person I
believe this guy was second
congratulations and who were you running
for I'm running for Jennifer parks in in
memory yes and how fast do you how fast
did you finish the Finish Line I
finished uh
18 16 18 16 and why were you out here
today running why was it so special to
do you're obviously a runner why was it
extra special to be out here today for
this race we're here to support uh in
memory of all these people lost their
lives on October 2nd and uh we're here
so do not care about these people thank
you so much for uh for support Channel 8
is the race of course so they can
keep our supervisor races like this one
I think thank you so much now go drink
some water some Gatorade and at least
we'll see carbs when you finish a race
like that how fast are these guys all
right I'm gonna send it back to Nate and
Heather back over to you guys
[Music]
all right JC really it's just incredible
oh my gosh so the guy who was first he
just pranced right around us like he's
still running yeah but he had a huge
smile on his face cool down oh my God
cool down mode all right uh Clark County
of course we had mentioned yesterday you
know such an important day here in our
city hosted its annual traditional
Sunrise Service uh yesterday morning
yeah so this is something that they've
done every year since one October the
county along with Metro pausing to
remember uh featuring live music and an
honor guard there was a minute of
silence for the victims there were
remarks from governor sisalak and
Sheriff Lombardo
foreign
yes we are following the shooting you
know items ranging from flowers to
everything everybody brought stuff at
the to the various memorials all over
town it really was incredible to see
that you know the bulk of those items
left at the crosses there um at the the
welcome to Las Vegas sign a lot of items
in fact about 22 000 pieces make up an
entire collection now that's stored at
the Clark County Museum and those
exhibits focuses on the stories behind
the certain items you know really
emphasizing Vegas strong as a
celebration of how the community came
together in the days following the
tragedy and following the shooting even
in the weeks following one October in
fact the collection is going to remain
on display at the Clark County Museum
until the end of January and
unfortunately Heather we're coming up on
the end of our broadcast here we
certainly we just started I know it went
by quicker than some of those runs I
think
thank you so much for tuning in Raiders
now is next on 8 news now thanks Heather
thank you everyone thank you now the
Smoke Clears all tears Spilled Out on
the event ground blood and cell phones
ringing intent to tear us down lose our
way and drown take away our peas very
hope deep underground but no not here
fool you don't have the tools to
deconstruct us a name demon killed many
but inspired more scars made but love
saved scars made but hope safe near
misses and lost kisses scattered in the
hot wind of Vegas as those who escaped
such evil lived to tell it shout it
scream it alive alive we are alive we
will live for those you left behind
killed from the tower but didn't kill
hope nope carry on and do no wrong you
just can't kill love we are still Vegas
strong
thank you
[Music]